look how happy these guys are
they are living the life
which is why i had to get one myself
because they look so damn happy
and i miss having a hot tub
so i got myself an inflatable
coleman
sally spa
and it was tight because i got on amazon
and it came in two days
so i gotta build this
i got an audience
i don't know if tiger likes it or not
but
i do miss
our other backyard
where we just go on the back and just
chill and have a good relaxing time and
my favorite when it's cold like right
now when it's cold and the water is
boiling that feels so good
so the building didn't go
i had uh
some uh the peanut m ms or almond m m's
and you know when you get almonds and it
starts flaking it gets in the back of
your throat
but the building didn't get very far
until i got tantalized
with some peas
and chips yeah wow you guys know how to
relax
with your baby
damn look at that pizza though oh this
is yesterday's leftovers i know
sometimes that's my favorite oh damn i
saw that cheese just stretch did you see
that that's some stretchy cheese
let's see
i apologize sir the eyes open all right
so we
randomly wanted to get ice cream we're
two minutes away but taika is literally
falling asleep in front of our eyes
and i hope we can make it we're just two
minutes away okay monkey we got this you
could do this he's gonna fall asleep
right in front of his watch
look you can do it i believe in you
i believe in you i think you've got it
now okay good there you go there you go
i see those eyes they're strong they're
strong eyes those are strong eyes
there we go
are we gonna make it i think we're gonna
make it okay okay
there we go
that's what i'm talking about good job
duty we got two more minutes dude just
go fast let's look at those eyes
let's go fast i think okay i think he's
good i think he's good okay we're good
all right
so this is so cuny because me and mama
bear after we ate pizza we're just uh
snuggling on the couch it's actually us
three because every time me and margaret
snuggle taika always comes out of
nowhere and he wants to come in too so
we just have one big family snugglefest
and then what'd you say you're like
you're like
anybody want ice cream like oh so you
want to go get ice cream right now and
he goes ube ice cream and i'm like even
better i know
and i'm like i guess the spa will not
get built but i don't care because ice
cream's delicious let's see this check
up on those eyes they're good i think
we're back i don't see any more lids but
earlier those those eyelids were
feet i know earlier he was like this
he's like smiley yeah and it just he has
like he's like i'm so excited for ice
cream
good job
hey good job
this guy is so smart
for me that's very true
because uh one time we were like oh
let's go get some food and he goes where
i'm like in chinatown are you tricking
me because i think he thought chinatown
was a different country and i'm like no
like chinatown like a lot of cities have
chinatowns and then he goes okay now he
understands i'm like oh you see those
chinese words he goes oh cool we're in
chinatown and then he saw that
over there
and where did you say we're at monkey
good job you're so smart dude
you're so funny
thank you
[Music]
ice cream
all right so after ice cream he finally
got his nap
he did it he succeeded he waited
ate the entire thing literally you guys
saw how big that ice cream was he ate
the whole thing
now we're going back on our way home
like this place isn't even like more
than 50 minutes away and within like
three minutes of just the car ride
those curtains got real heavy
and the show was over
so i'm back
we'll probably wait in the car a little
bit or i will pop i think you're going
to assemble the
jackets
my eyes are getting kind of oh jesus you
too
yeah okay why don't we just bring them
out bring them onto the couch well i
think you're about supposed to do this
bring them out bring them up
okay
so papa is sleeping
we were trying to put daika down for a
nap but he just wasn't sleepy but he
tried to stall hearts i'm so proud of
him
okay what are we doing right now
what are we doing
okay you're gonna make it
okay so we got the old school popcorn
but hey why are we whispering stop
sleeping okay okay
[Music]
okay
okay hold on i'm gonna put you guys down
look over there go for their monkey
you ready dude
let's pull it
back first you're gonna crack your back
okay go
oh
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Applause]
this is so noisy
[Music]
[Music]
shaking
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
shake it though
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
it's growing dude keep shaking your eyes
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
look
so
it's done
[Music]
okay we're done
look
don't touch it okay it's hot
yeah we're gonna get popcorn you ready
let's go watch venom you got your water
okay let's go let's see if papa's still
sleeping
come on
look at this
hey
you're not sleeping
was it all this noise that we made no
you want some popcorn
no it looks like a spaceship
is it hot yeah yeah yeah yeah it was
just over the flame yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so we're gonna
watch venom now
whoa dude what are you doing that big
old knife i'm gonna cut this with that
okay try it
gotta want to burn yourself you wanna
bring yourself no
oh
it really works
how are you gonna open it now
you can also just rip it open
there you go
enjoy you enjoy it
you made it for me too yeah made it for
both of us help yourself dude look at
that yummy yummy no we don't need it
anymore because you're gonna it's just
gonna spill everywhere there that's it
that's it that's it that's it don't open
it anymore
one second
okay so i have a feeling
jacuzzi's not gonna be inflated today
[Music]
see
the sun setting what's happening would
you say what'd you say nothing nothing
what'd you say i'm about something
what'd you say the sun is setting so
let's just lower our conversations i'm
about something what you say nothing
we're talking some smack or what
well we have to do our grocery shopping
now yeah we do
but what'd you say
nothing
block it too
it's [ __ ] cold out there
i think it's 55 degrees and he's not
wearing anything we'll see how long he
lasts
right now it's 4
36.
i think he's gonna start saying it's
cold soon
see you later papa
all right this is pretty crazy
so i finally got to building the hot tub
today
and i'm opening these boxes
and this thing has a freaking control
panel
that's crazy
because this is like some i don't know
it's like looks like some temporary
thing you bring
to like a camp site or a camping trip or
whatever and it has a legit
control panel
that'll actually tell
the temperature
because based off how this looks like
how it's just inflatable
i thought it was going to be one of
those things where it's just hot or cold
or something
that is sick
what
is going on i told you when you married
me i was gonna live a good life you were
gonna live the good life with this
inflatable hot tub well you feel how
chilly it is out here yeah imagine
getting hot water
this is amazing but why aren't we
getting the backyard done cheapo
we're gonna get there but look at where
i'm placing it right underneath the
audience
that's
how luxurious i'm so gonna be i'm so
lucky i told you look at the our
expensive fire grill oh my god
look at this tyka's gym set i'm so lucky
how are you gonna inflate this it comes
with everything oh cool watch look look
at the instructions cause i was looking
for the paper like a pamphlet it doesn't
have one and then it says
easy setup
no tools needed
inflate with pump attach pump fill with
water oh my god if a
i hear things are happening oh my god
no don't shoot at people look at this
that was crazy
freaking kid
how cool so it comes with its own thing
what is this
the filter and everything this is all in
one wow tell me you're going to live a
life of luxury when you're living it's
like shut up
i turn on the lights for you oh thank
you mama
do you think they turn themself on
that's so fast
i have a feeling you're going to get in
it tonight if it gets hot enough
because our old hot tub in our first
house it took 24 hours to get hot oh
okay but this is larger it's smaller oh
okay so
you should have put like a mat or
something underneath
what i don't know
at least cardboard boxes so there's not
a rock or anything
that punctures it
this looks very sketch babe
i don't know about this
this is like office supply baby
oh my god
we are so bootleg we're the most bootleg
neighbors out here
we live in a million dollar home
and this is our backyard equipment
this is taika's jungle gym
our grill
we're straight trash
what the [ __ ] is that
oh
that noise it's equivalent to like
someone scratching their someone's
scratching their nails down a blackboard
oh sorry if i made you feel like
that [ __ ] was